man deterrence what we're seeing is a  crime wave around the world what did you  do this weekend me nothing very  interesting  no protective shoes  [Music]  no nutcase  [Music]  who could come here  [Music]  there were four  I call this one this is the day so mums  biggest concern for exploding windup  penguins by the devil on his army you  know  starting games alone to do this together  I mean cool you ready to do battle  [Music]  relaxed offered I'll take it from here  uh do I know you  [Music]  [Music]  as well  we all have to recognize  that's it how many of you are there not  enough do you really think oh wow they  just they really just vanish  oh that's rude you said you'd come  now that's hope you're not too late  you